étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai récemment assisté au mro
Americas à Atlanta et j'ai vu l'une des
choses les plus incroyables que j'aie jamais vues de
ma vie, c'est exactement ce que vous regardez,
c'est un saut de CFM  Moteur 1B
construit entièrement en Legos il a été construit
par Lufthansa Technic le moteur lui-même
est construit à 60 de la taille réelle du
moteur et il est composé de plus de 400 000
pièces de Legos pèse environ 992 livres
depuis longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le son revient
merci
maintenant je comprends que tu aimes
aussi la guitare
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons que tu aies son signe
rendons l'Amérique Glam à nouveau